لن يوافق ملك البرجر نفسه بالتأكيد
على العلامة
التي أنشأها أتباعه ، فنحن جميعًا نستقيل
آسف للإزعاج اقرأ
الرسالة خارج هذا lincoln nebraska
burger king
الذي أزعج الموظفين هنا كانت
ظروف العمل التي وصفوها
مثل مكيفات مكسورة في المطبخ تدفع
درجات الحرارة  في التسعينيات ،
كان الجو حارًا للغاية ، تقول المديرة راشيل
فلورز إنها انتهى بها المطاف في المستشفى وهي
تحصل على سوائل من الجفاف
عندما أعطت إشعارًا لمدة أسبوعين ، وكذلك فعل
ثمانية من
موظفيها ، وفي نهاية تلك الفترة ،
ظهرت رسالتهم إلى الإدارة  أردنا ضحكة كبيرة لهم ، لذا
فإن كل ما تركناه جميعًا
كان لهم بشكل أساسي مع الأسف
لإزعاج العملاء ، فقد انتشرت العلامة على نطاق واسع
نشرت أحد المعلقين ، وليس لدي أي شيء سوى
الاحترام
والشغف المؤسف
لكرواسون بالبيض والجبن
ولكن يعتقد الآخرون ذلك  كان العمال
الذين وضعوا بيضة على وجوههم ، وكان
الأطفال الصغار يبكون ويتغلبون عليها مرحبًا
بهم لكونهم بالغين
، كانت الساعة حوالي السادسة صباحًا  عندما
ساعد المدير فلوريس عاملًا مستقيلًا آخر في
تغيير الحروف الموجودة على اللافتة
، كان الأمر يتناوب بشكل أو بآخر
كما تعلم لأنه في الواقع نوع من
التعب عند وضع الرسائل هناك
بعد بضع ساعات ، تلقت مكالمة من
الإدارة
العليا وأخبرني  كنت بحاجة إلى
إزالته وأخبرته أنني لا أستطيع فعل ذلك
لأننا لم يكن لدينا فريق عمل صغير وكان الغداء
قد بدأ للتو
قريبًا جاء رئيس آخر يسأل عن
مفتاحها وأصدرت بطاقتها من برجر كينج بيانًا
تجربة العمل الموصوفة في هذا
الموقع هي  لا يتماشى مع قيم علامتنا التجارية ،
يبحث صاحب الامتياز في
هذا الموقف لضمان عدم
حدوث ذلك
في المستقبل بعد ما يقرب من
ست ساعات ،
تم استبدال علامة تركنا جميعًا بتعيين جداول زمنية مرنة الآن
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتخلي عن وظائفهم
قرر هؤلاء العمال أن يحصلوا
على طريقتهم
المارد cnn
رجل جديد يورك أنت